[Music]
in oh hell no news on are submitted by
geo look away it's about kids or animals
yeah you right what about me the elderly
she also has I do it was your second yes
animal could be for straight white man I
don't have you know the soft spot for
straight women Bob no everyone else sure
[Laughter]
Texas what a burger was shut down after
a mouse was caught on camera jumping
into the fryer he saw ratatouille he got
inspired he was like man I want to make
burgers in there like not may leave
gonna kill you is like I'll take my life
first it never take me alive
[Music]
Sandy's older brother look away but it
is sad yeah we need to talk about the
rat community do we have to watch it yes
yes am i watching it I like rats rats
don't find them cute
well specific and you know Mouse's are
cuter swell yeah difference between a
rat and rats [ __ ] huge they get
really huge in mice are like the little
what did you have mice have rounder
heads those are small too well cuz they
were small
they're small rats - no I mean as they
get older they get bigger oh yeah now
that their bodies are like oval yeah but
then rats are more like a pair mice once
a rat reaches a certain length that
becomes a rat oh yeah might meet me
there deny it's not a mouse goes in the
right No
like pigs if you if they're wild they
turn into rust exactly he's right
it's like hamsters and guinea pigs
they're different they're the thing it's
like pigs eventually grow into hogs if
they live long that's true no that's
wrong
all right so what's the difference
between a red and a mouse a mature mouse
can be distinguished from a young rat by
its large ears and longer tail compared
to its body length than the rest a young
rat also has distinctly larger feet and
head compared to the body than a mouse
mice are usually light gray or brown in
color with a lighter show you have on
their bellies oh that makes sense old
mouse big ears like Mickey Mouse yeah
rats have small ears that's why it's not
Mickey Ratt Oh when they clean their
ears Mickey rat would not sell the same
merchants Mickey Mickey right does not
become a billion dollar corporation if
it's Ricky rat smoking come on kids get
on on the ride it ride Chuckie Cheese
Chucky's I read it's all about
alliteration Chuckie oh please he's a
mouse yeah big ears he looks like a
dirty rat he does look crazy he's fully
adult he that that means he's Ricky Ray
can we make it look to me like a rat
smoke to see Ricky rap one of my joys of
parenthood was taking kids to chuck a
cheese when he comes out they're
freaking terrified Ricky rat yeah
because I kind of want to make a Ricky
rat t-shirt no what are you talking
about I don't know I just made him up
but then he didn't really because it was
bad damn it I wanted to make it well
that does it what if we called it Mickey
yeah how about that
looky Lenny's ice yeah it's a leaky let
you just jumped in there that's so
[ __ ] sad I wonder what he tasted like
after ruff Oh with all that beef fat in
the oil probably pretty good fry man
[Music]
now do it jail you can't stop me a bit
to it now I don't deal you're not here
to save me you don't love me he's
already contemplating it on the side
[Applause]
not an instant killed in he was watching
to see what was gonna happen
that's a double kill Oh Ricky
it's oddly satisfying almost like man it
was really intense so I hope they
drained that I don't know if you guys
heard but the lady was like I don't know
how to turn it off like they're trying
to tell her I could just turn up yeah
it's instant kill yours does nothing you
couldn't wonder how often they day like
drain that grease don't think about a
job I used to work at Burger King not as
often as you think is that what's a week
right once a week and sometimes less
than that does it taste better toward
the end of the week because all the rats
were in there all the germs get burned
up anyway from the heat right you
because I call it season that's true you
don't get a fresh batch of french fries
from the fresh oil - doesn't taste that
it doesn't so they were saying water
burger said that they closed down the
store they also gave refunds back to
people who hadn't gotten their food yet
and even so the guys filming the video
towards the end he's they're asking like
who didn't get a refund and he was like
I did it and then she was like but you
already got your food he's like I
haven't eaten it yet and you get some
his receipt he's like here's my receipt
I want my [ __ ] rebuttals in there
that's so bad about having a mouse or
rat I don't know people are stupid
people are just getting triggered Bart
there's control triggered it just means
that you're not maintaining it boom boom
it's not a clean place like it could be
rat poo poo everywhere yeah yes it's
just not clean that's how they have to
show how do you not know that yeah a car
game so for me like I assume fast food
dirty is [ __ ] I assume it's dirty as
[ __ ] you assume at all times of the
desert dirty is that dirty rat dirty
mouths turd
I seen you get McDonald's oh you're not
getting McDonald's like like because
like but almost but I'm assuming yeah
but I'm assuming it's that dirty and I'm
and I'm okay with it like when I went on
this tour Kentucky tour and it's like a
tour group and we went to this place in
London ah this place and give more
business in London
it's very infamous for having the best
Indian food I went to an Indian
restaurant
a cockroach comes on the table that's
[ __ ] you think its culture everyone
freaks out and I'm like why are you
freaking out you're like this is part of
the culture I still ate there after you
saw the roach yeah it's just one don't
clean
we got wages at our house if we clean
all the time we do clean but it was only
roaches because the house was vacant for
so long so now this movement because
we're cleaning it's another rolling away
Bart normal people see a roach crawl
across the table and they don't want to
eat there anymore it was a brand new
built like house that's been vacant for
like months that's I'm sure so the
roaches like they ain't nobody in your
bro is cool because it was more than one
they'd be telling their friends groans
you'll love now there's no more because
they know there's people here they're
dying left and right
they're cleaning in here they're
spraying we gotta go somewhere else we
gotta go to water burger into London I
expect rats and bugs everywhere at
restaurants I don't Martin do you want
that bird I don't either but we didn't
have money we'd have it was people that
were gross but we didn't have dirt gonna
have roaches and rats part if you're at
a Michelin star restaurant and you see a
roach calling the table will you be
pissed that I will okay good because not
a fat fast food like even like you know
the food trucks before before food
trucks were a fan truck things they used
to call them Roach coaches oh yeah yeah
okay Roach coach fast food that's that
John Roach Indian food wasn't wasn't
fast food but because of how like the
dingy part of London it was in it was
just like you can kind of smell distant
sewer water like it was just like okay
cool it's part of the culture or
whatever here I'm just hungry if I'm
hungry [ __ ]
it depends on how hungry I am
do I want to return this do I want to
step out and go to a different
restaurant it's like if I'm hungry
no roaches stopping me what two hours
later you're like [ __ ] out of your
[ __ ] [ __ ] and your mouth I already
forgot how that happened but it's
different because those are cultivating
or there's a farm you know in Amman with
these other ones these are hood
free-range roaches better than farm
that's a free-range discriminating you
know I think sorry Ranger wrote to me
the funniest thing I ever heard it's
ravings
with the free-range mouth now I remember
it was a soup the brim see I think it's
six Oden it's the it's the Japanese yes
okay yeah and around the rim you can see
how it's caked up [ __ ] yeah over the if
so they never clean that it's the same
broad of of things it's boiling for like
50 years
do you guys ever barbecue like sometimes
you barbecue you put on the side you put
it on the side
sometimes a bunch of flies go on it
right you just take the meat and then
you just kind of throw it back on in
Kakinada journalist that's fine dude
that is bad no I throw a while to meet
away that just happened at a barbecue
out of my house you throw the meat away
from fly land he's saying he already
cooked it and then he just put it back
on so that it burns off listen when
you're barbecuing like sometimes you
can't but man the Flies may be nefarious
they hop on the thing they start doing
that either
oh yeah we better get into this wait I
thought they lay eggs in that [ __ ] if
you did they do for long enough I don't
think they do it I've heard they do it
as soon as they touch them yeah like
I'll make carne asada right it's on the
side and then I'm like before I even put
a lid on things jump on it real quick oh
[ __ ] I'm with you brother because I
think come on stays a little too bougie
I think nah man I can't eat the fly too
little too bougie I'll never tell you
maybe after if I don't know cuz your
mind sees it like I would been at that
water burger and I didn't know that bird
would been fired same here now watch
them uh you should come to a cookout at
Bart's and when he walks up to you
holding a burger like this Oh
charcoal fingers more classmen I know
I'm married too humble please don't
judge me by his actions
free-range cockroaches is an elegant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]